Here's the identity of the celestial goddess
Queen
What did I come here for?
The culprit is annihilated,
I'll kill The
disease has begun to move
Returning to the neighborhood The brutal feeling of death is crushed by the edge of the hounds
Beyond the story Tomorrow will not come to you You ca
n't escape from The
real culprit is definitely the ghost God
prefers perfection and harmony  Those who scream, run, and bleed in the midst of the storms of a few occurrences In
front of the strength of their souls,
you and I have no choice but to stand still
. Let's
go, everyone.  Let's unite the
detective agency one more time Using this
life as fuel, we'll
fly forever The
sermon
Always because of the experience of the order of the country in the past, the charge
will exercise the strongest violence
Humans are sinful and stupid, but they
're not as boring as you think
Hope  came into view
[music]